some ways
[Music]
Ariana Grande has a wickedly epic way of
reminding fans why she hasn't dropped
new music do you do whatever you want
whatever you want whatever feels natural
felt natural singing Ari who's currently
shooting the film adaptation of the
Broadway musical Wicked responds to fans
asking her why aren't you still a singer
she writes I'm literally on set filming
two musical movies all day every day and
to prove to fans she still got it Ariana
then belts out an acapella cover of
Somewhere Over the Rainbow of course
from The Wizard of Oz another movie
musical taking place in author L frank
Baum's Aussie and universe
foreign
[Music]
I always listen to their feedback and
try to incorporate as much of it as I
can while also remaining as you know
true to my Artistry as I possibly can in
the video Ari also notes she was mid
getting ready and hiding the blonde
locks she wears for her character Glinda
which was made popular on Broadway by
Kristin Chenoweth Popular
[Music]
I've known Ariana Grande since she was
10. so Ariana I'm very very proud of you
she knows we talk every day I love you
baby girl and it's an honor and a
pleasure to pass the wand and the crown
to you I'm the mentor but I'm also the
mentee because I'm learning from her as
well Ariana's been sharing sneak peeks
from the set which includes pics with
her Wicked co-star Cynthia arrivo who's
taking on the character Elphaba that is
uh special that the both of us are
working really really hard and we're
trying to bring you something that you
might not expect it is not going to be
too far away hopefully from the stage
but I think you'll get more from it now
I think you'll get more of the story of
the two of these wonderful characters
who have lots of life to give Andy star
studded cast is only getting bigger as
Golden Globe winning actress Michelle yo
joins as Madame morable the headmistress
of creej Hall
and one and two thank you John Chu you
know for believing in me and I think
it's a really really juicy role I told
him I don't sing you realize I don't
sing I've never sung before but it was
very interesting last year while we were
doing all these interviews and people
would ask you know which Universe would
you want to be and what would you like
to do and both Jamie Lee and I went we
want to be singers we want to be in the
universe where we have rock stars and we
and at that time you know I said I'd
love to be in a musical lo and behold
it manifested and while we wait for the
two Wicked films to come out which will
be Christmas 2024 and 2025. we'll just
keep playing Ari's rendition of
Somewhere Over the Rainbow on repeat so
world for the rainbow
it's nice
[Music]
really do come true